while sky high prices in grocery stores
are getting a lot of attention there's
another issue that is often overlooked
the growing amount of food waste
according to researchers at penn state
university the average american
household wastes more than eighteen
hundred dollars worth of food each year
good housekeeping deputy nutrition
director stephanie sassos joins us with
tips on how to extend the life of your
groceries cut down on food waste and
something we all should do
save you some money good morning
stephanie how are you doing good thank
you for having me it's great to be here
glad you're here so you say to prevent
food waste it starts with proper food
storage how so totally well the first
thing to make sure that you're noting is
in the fridge you don't want to
overcrowd that fridge you want to keep a
little space in between items that way
you can allow the cold air to circulate
keep your food fresh that really does
start at the grocery store not over
buying only getting what you need right
or buying oh i am guilty
and it's true you know there's different
temperature zones throughout the fridge
as well the back of the fridge is the
coldest section the front of the fridge
is the warmest area and the top shelf is
warmer than the bottom shelf so keep
that in mind for highly perishable goods
anything like meat dairy products put
that towards the back of the fridge and
in those fridge doors up front maybe
more like your condiments your water
bottles things like that that aren't
going to spoil as easily do containers
make a difference whether it's plastic
bags or whether it's plastic containers
or glass containers with the lids
containers make a huge difference and at
the good housekeeping institute and the
kitchen appliances lab we vigorously
test containers of all different types
so our top pick is these rubbermaid
brilliance containers they're plastic
they have a great tight fitting seal on
the top with the lid they're highly
portable super convenient that's good
for on the go and then at home some
glass containers investing in a good
set's a great idea our top pick is from
truseal and the nice thing about those
they can go from the fridge to the
freezer to the oven
up to 425 degrees fahrenheit so really
versatile and i don't know about you
growing up we had a million containers
and where are the lids all mismatched
you know so investments
exactly invest in a good set it's worth
it all right so you say something that's
interesting you say freezers are an ally
in helping cut down on food waste but i
feel like if you look at my fridge we
have meat in there from like the
jurassic era
you know it's been in there since like
forever meaning we don't waste a lot of
food it all gets shoved you don't even
see the light when you turn on the you
don't even know what it is you're like
what
is this and it's covered with ice burn
right well it's a good idea at least
once a week to really take inventory of
what's in the fridge and freezer
especially in the freezer even with the
best intentions things can get lost in
the back but your freezer is the
ultimate tool for reducing food waste i
want you to think anytime something is
about to turn can i freeze it yes and
you know there's a few different hacks
with that i know gail before you were
asking me about bananas bananas yeah so
that's a big one i think we're all we've
all seen it all the bananas over ripe on
the on the table at the end of the week
right so i want you to peel them you're
going to slice them and then put them on
a baking sheet or a plate lined with
parchment paper you want to freeze it in
those slices if you just throw them all
in a bag it's going to get into a big
clump yeah you won't be able to use it
what's the point right yeah once they're
frozen then you can put it in some sort
of food airtight container or in a bag
another little hack is for herbs you
know we'll buy let's say a big thing of
parsley you only use about a tablespoon
or two yeah you need a little tiny bit
yeah a huge like a thing of parsley and
then you're stuck and it ultimately goes
in the trash well i want you to cut up
those herbs put them in an ice cube tray
with olive oil then you pop them out put
them on the skillet oh okay
that's your flavor bomb that'll work
zephyr
open up a can what about expiration
dates like i have eggs right that's a
good march 29th i should buy march 29th
i know it's bad well girl what about the
hats in a little bit i don't i don't
cook but it was a while ago dates you
can use it past the expiration date or
yes
a lot of times you'll see a date on
there and you assume it's an expiration
date and you have to throw it out
immediately well typically these dates
are best by date sell by dates or use by
dates they're more indicative of quality
and flavor not necessarily that they've
gone bad so signs of spoilage you want
to look for a change in color a weird
texture an unpleasant odor exactly and
the obvious things you know molds a
bulging lid things of that nature can
also be a sign but the usda food safety
and inspection service says most of
these things are perfectly okay to
consume after the date not march 29th
though but i think that's a little
we'll be right back